[Musique]
le département lance une campagne de
sensibilisation d'information et de
prévention contre les addictions une
campagne innovante et 100% local qui
sera déployé en télévision et en digital
sur les réseaux sociaux
nous avons utilisé toutes sortes de
supports pour aller le plus loin
possible parce que nous voulons
sensibiliser le jeune en particulier ses
parents la communauté éducative
en fait tous et toutes les personnes qui
côtoient au quotidien va des personnes
en situation de fragilité fragilité
parce que la vie n'est pas simple il ya
le problème du chômage
il ya le problème parfois des échecs
scolaires qui fragilise aussi bien aux
jeunes comme les parents et donc la
tentation d'aller vers des addictions
à ce moment là elle est grande il
convient de dire allons du thé résister
ne tombez pas dans le piège de ses
addictions
c'est une campagne de prévention qui ne
s'arrête pas cette campagne de
communication qui va durer six mois qui
est un point d'orgue important parce que
c'est la première fois qu'une
collectivité à dans l'île à ma
connaissance lance une campagne de
prévention de cette ampleur de
communication de cette ampleur mais
derrière on va renforcer
l'accompagnement des associations qui
agissent au quotidien dans le domaine de
la prévention en matière d'alcoolisme de
l'addiction de façon générale parce
qu'il ya pas que l'alcool et le tabac il
ya maintenant des drogues dures qui
arrive à la réunion donc dans le cadre
de l'année 2021 on va renforcer des
actions auprès notamment de ces
associations c'est un plan global que
l'on met en place je rappelle aussi qu
avec notamment le professeur doré nous
avons sensibilisé nos travailleurs
sociaux sur la question de l'alcoolisme
foetal pour keep que ces travailleurs
connaissent mieux ce qu'est l'alcoolisme
total pour qu'ils en parlent mieux
auprès des femmes des publics fragilisés
qui pourraient être à risque de tomber
dans cette situation la réunion est un
territoire qui reste fragile avec 40 %
des réunionnais qui vivent sous le seuil
de pauvreté avec des inégalités plus
marquée qu'en métropole
les jeunes sont donc très exposée à
l'inactivité à l'exclusion sociale cette
fragilité propice au développement de
l'addiction en particulier
alors les addictions aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose qui sont les cumuls à peu
près tout
qui doit faire à peu près mille décès
par an quand on cumule toutes les
addictions pour l'alcool c'est près de
450 décès pour le tabasser 550 blessés
voilà donc je pourrais vous donner
beaucoup d'autres chiffres c'est et
c'est un processus qui par contre
commence dans la majorité des cas 80% à
peu près avant 18 ans c'est pour ça
vraiment il est fondamental de prévenir
les addictions auprès de cette
population et même de s'adresser avant
l'adolescent ensemble dans la mesure
possible avec des campagnes de
prévention avec des actions de
prévention qu'ils soient accessibles et
adaptés à ceux à ce public pour prévenir
l'émergence des addictions pour
minimiser les conséquences de celles et
ceux qui ont déjà commencé des pratiques
addictives briller c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet compliqué que de faire de la
prévention à travers cette campagne de
sensibilisation le département pour
objectif de susciter une prise de
conscience en particulier contre les
addictions à l'alcool au tabac et à mal
[Musique]